Can you mention the various names and
attributes which Allah subhana wa ta'ala
uses to describe the Quran
in the Quran or with the Quran.
There are many empty number of
attributes and names used by Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala in the Quran for the
Quran. I'll just mention a few that that
I can recollect immediately.
Allah refers to the Quran as the Furan
the criteria to judge right from wrong
in surah furan chapter 25 verse number
one and there's a full chapter chapter
number 25
named after that criteria to judge right
from wrong it's also in surah bakar
chapter 2 verse number 85 the word
forkan is used
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala also describes
the Quran as tanzil that is a revelation
in surah Chapter number 26 verse number
192 it is described as that is the
message in surah amia chapter number 21
verse number 50 it's also described as
the kab that's the book kab is called as
the book also as the wahi as a
revelation in surah yuf chapter number
12 verse number one it is described as n
meaning the light in surah nisa 4 verse
number 174 it is described as huda
meaning guidance in surah bakar chapter
2 verse number two as well as surah
bakar chapter 2 verse number 185 it is
described as rahma meaning blessings in
surahman
chapter number 31 verse number 3 it's
also described as majid meaning glorious
in surah burj chapter number 85 verse
number 21 it is called as mubarak
meaning blessings in surah sad chapter
number 38 verse number 29 it is
described as bashir mean the good news
in surah fusil chapter 41 verse number
four it is called as nad meaning
admonition in surah chapter 41 verse
number four it is called asalam the word
of Allah in surah tba chapter number 9
verse number 6 it's also referred to as
moa that is the instruction
in surah al Iran vers 138. It's also
referred to as shifa that is healing in
surah Isra chapter number 17 verse
number 82 and it's also called as mubin
meaning easily understood in surf 12
verse number one these are the various
names and attributes and several others
which Allah has referred to the Quran in
the Quran
>> so subhan Allah have you ever counted
them there seems to be a number
>> there are many I think many bal and I
you can keep on adding if you keep on
thinking
>> no I wonder they refer to it often is
the astonishing Quran. Alhamdulillah.